hey everyone today let's talk about rpa
or robotic process automation
in my opinion the definition lies more
in the terms process automation
and lessen actual robots but rpa is
changing the software world
much like physical robots have changed
the world that we live in every day
for example take a vending machine
there's not a person standing there
sorting all your money
and bending the goods it's automated
because it's a tedious task
now rpa is doing the same thing in the
software world
for tedious repetitive tasks but for
things like
it or even business process management
rpa is not going to help and that's
because these require more specialized
skills
so where can rpa assist well
let's start with an example inspired by
one of my favorite tv shows
let's say we've got a disgruntled
employee we're going to call him pete
now pete has to take a number of
documents
that are stored you know digitally and
then convert them
into forms that he then has to file
so this is a very tedious task so he has
to take all of these forms
write them out manually and then
finally actually go and file them
so this process let's see has to do this
you know 10 000 times
that means you know pete's going to be
pretty unhappy about this
because this is a very tedious
repetitive task it's something that you
know with rpa he could actually automate
so let's see what pete would do if he
wanted to set up an automation to do
this flow
so the first thing he has to do is
identify what's the data where is it
coming from
so in this particular example the data
is already in
a computer somewhere and let's say
that's coming in through
email or maybe his co-worker kelly
is manually inputting them from you know
phone calls with customers
so they take the customer forms they
they put them into the computer
now pete has to extract data right so
that's going to be the first thing that
rpa can help with
now so with ocr or
optical character recognition along with
the data that's in the computer
pete's able to pull out data and what's
what he's going to do is actually
extract that data
for further processing so that data can
be things like
the customer's name and the info
let's say in the customer form it's the
complaints that make up that information
so taking that data so the next thing
pete's going to do
is let's say validate it so make sure
that none of the data is corrupt
and you know all the data looks good
finally he has to input it into a
digital form
so he puts it into a digital form
and finally he sends it off to a printer
now at this phase all pete really has to
do
is take the final forms that are printed
out and then file them
and that's going to be a whole lot
easier to do than doing this
manually for all 10 000 customer
complaint forms that are coming in
so that's where rpa can really assist
with tedious repetitive tasks
that require things like clicking
through user interfaces
copying and pasting data or kind of
other things like
optical character recognition where you
have to extract data
so when choosing an rpa solution which
is going to enable you to do
this type of automation i'd say there's
four major things that you really need
to be looking for
now the first one i'm going to start
with you want to make sure
that your rpa tool is intelligent
now in this particular flow pete used a
lot of capabilities so he used ocr
optical character recognition in
addition he used different data
manipulation techniques
so this enables pete to do things like
extract input data validate it
and finally he even had a function to be
able to print something out
create a physical piece of paper from a
software-based automation
that's just scratching the tip of what
robot rpa can do today
so another thing rpa can do is things
like ai or
machine learning to train a model to
recognize not just
you know simple characters but maybe
even images so that's something that
pete might want to augment this
automation with in the future
so that's one thing you want to make
sure is that your rpa tool is
intelligent
number two low code
so rpa is really only going to be
effective if the users that are creating
these automation
find that process to be easy otherwise
management might choose to actually just
have their employees do it manually
if creating this type of automation was
too time consuming
so a low code rpa environment is going
to enable pete to do things like drag
and drop
components and have minimal touch to
actually get this automation created end
to end
number three concurrency
so this is going to be the ability to
run multiple robots at the same time
multiple automation tasks
so for the 10 000 customer complaint
forms say this task takes 15 seconds
that's a lot of time so imagine if you
could launch
multiple robots and divvy up that work
well
you could get through the task at hand
much more quickly so an rpa solution
should have concurrency support
and the last one i want to mention here
is
rpa as a service now an as a service
model is going to come with a number of
advantages
for one it's going to give you shorter
time to value
and that's because pete doesn't have to
worry about spinning up his own
infrastructure
installing the software managing that
environment
he can just log in and start building
these automations
right away that brings me to my next
point
currency so not concurrency but currency
which is keeping up with the latest
versions that are available
so rpa in the world of rpa is changing
quite rapidly
and so with some of the intelligent
capabilities enabled within rpa
say a new version of ocr comes out and
he wants to use it
well with an rpa as a service capability
you can get updates more quickly
you're more current with the latest
versions of software so you get to use
those latest components
and maybe ocr 2.0 kind of helps fix some
of the bugs with
pulling data from customer complaint
forms
finally i think the last one that i want
to mention here is that
it allows you to collaborate so imagine
that pete builds this automation
publishes it and then now wants to share
it with
the the nashua branch of this company so
that they can take advantage of the same
process
to automate this flow and and kind of
file customer complaint forms
so as a service environments generally
are multi-tenant and enable you to
collaborate with your co-workers
so this was a quick overview of rpa rpa
tools are quickly growing in popularity
and so is the scope of what rpa is able
to actually automate
now if you like this video have any
questions or comments be sure to
drop a like or a comment below as always
stay tuned and subscribe for more videos
like this in the future
thank you rpa is growing very rapidly
and the scope
of what rpa is able to automate is also
growing rapidly
now if you want to see what ibm is doing
in the rpa space be sure to check out
the links in the description below